welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jun Saito assistant professor of
political science at Yale professor
Saito's research focuses on the
institutional determinants of
representation and redistribution in
particular how choices of constitutional
structures and electoral institutions
translate into redistributed
consequences he teaches courses on
Japanese politics international
relations in East Asia and comparative
political institutions from 2002 to 2003
professor Saito was a member of the
Japanese House of Representatives today
we'll talk with him about the end of the
Liberal Democratic Party in Japan
welcome professor Seidel hi until very
recently the same political party was in
control of the Japanese government for
more than 50 years why is that but there
are two factors one was that the Liberal
Democratic Party who has been a very
pragmatic party and it it did whatever
it could to stay in power it changed its
policy platform very flexibly whenever
it sensed the risk of electoral defeat
in future elections second the LDP was
the largest spending of pork barrel
money in the world for instance back in
the 1990s about 70% of the total
government construction projects among
OECD economies happened in the single
country Japan in some years the Japanese
government spend more money than on
construction projects government
construction projects than the US
government spent on their military in
terms of the gross amount that's how the
LDP stayed in power for such a long time
almost uninterrupted okay so I
understand that Japan has it been has
been a democracy during that period
and at the same party kept winning over
and over again is it because the people
simply liked the that party and its
policies Japan has been a democracy in
the sense that elections took place
periodically in a free country but on
the other hand what is puzzling is that
people did not necessarily like the
party at all if you take a look at
internationally comparable opinion poll
surveys for instance the Japanese
people's trust in the government
institutions and the politicians they
elect is the lowest among OECD economies
I mean the countries with advanced
industrial democracies okay and
additionally violent oppressions of
opposition party leaders for instance
have been absent which had been problem
problems in many other what is called
electro authoritarian regimes Japan was
different from those types of political
systems okay so what happened what
happened to the this Democratic Liberal
Party it's yes I'm sorry it's no longer
in power so what happened there are
several factors I'm actually writing a
book first of all the government has
almost exhausted the monetary resources
out of which they could slice policy
benefits to their supporters secondary
recent decentralization reform heart the
party significantly because the LDP
effectively committed the political
organization of suicide by firing their
lawyer party activists are the local
community levels in Japan unlike many
other democracies in the world local
politicians
who serve in the municipal legislatures
and mayor's for the almost paid
activists for the Democratic Party and
because of the recent municipal
government consolidation efforts pursued
by the LDP a large number of politicians
at the local level lost jobs and because
they were no longer faced elektra
pressures for themselves they lost the
incentive to campaign for the party and
I am arguing that that was the largest
mistake the LDP government okay so what
lessons can we learn from the Japanese
experience
well democracy is more than periodic
elections in order to have a healthy
democratic governance in a country we
need something that cept democratic
institutions in particular electro
institutions are the labor contract
between the citizens and the political
leaders if those rules of elections are
poorly designed citizens have difficulty
getting the job they want done by the
government and the Japanese example
provides abundant examples of such
failures okay let's talk about you and
your personal life you once served as a
member of the House of Representatives
in Japan what made you run for office
well I was young brave and naive I was
doctoral student in the ph.d program in
political science here at the Yale first
of all I was frustrated with the ongoing
corruption scandals in my hometown and
in my home district second I was in the
middle of drafting a dissertation on
pork barrel politics
in Japan and I did already plunged into
it myself and I thought that somebody
might have to show a viable alternative
to the conventional way or politics to
the voltage and I want the by-election
which fill the vacancy that was created
by a resignation of my predecessor who
was himself involved in a campaign
financial scandal mm-hmm okay so when
while you were in office what were some
of the things that you were able to
accomplish not much because I was there
but with that very brief experience my
social science background helped me a
lot in formulating policies my policy
proposals were later adopted by the DP
J's Elektra manifesto as a year the
normal amount of time that someone is
elected to actually very brief okay
my predecessor for instance and had
inherited his electro support base from
his father and his supporters his
supporters groups have been there for
more than half a century that's the idea
about actually many of the seeds are
effectively hereditary roughly half of
the politicians that belong to the
Liberal Democratic Party were
multi-generation politicians so it was
really amazing that you would have been
elected because the other candidate had
had so much to support so I ran from the
opposition party at that time in one of
the districts which was regarded as the
LDP's stronghold
there are several reasons one reason was
voters were obviously frustrated with
the way politics
taking place in the area
second because everybody knew that my
predecessor would try to come back
sometimes nobody was seriously
considering running and I simply
volunteered to run but because Japanese
voters place more emphasis on our script
therefore descriptive representation
they want the representatives who look
similar to themselves for that
particular reason I didn't emphasize
very much of my education instead I the
fact that I grew up in the farm and my
parents are still farming okay alright
let's talk about your newest work I
understand you're you have a new book
you're working on can you tell us about
it
yes my project is about everything it's
going to be about the end of the LDP
dominance in Japan but I'm writing a
book so that it will be useful and
interesting for scholars who study other
political systems for instance politics
of China or politics of Latin America
it's an analytical monograph with solid
empirical evidence and I hope it will
clarify many of the important paradoxes
and puzzles that sustain the LDP's
dominance in Japan okay so but the LDP
is no longer dominating that's correct
right what is the new party the
Democratic Party of Japan which is the
party I was formally affiliated with
form the new government in Japan I like
the Liberal Democratic Party which is a
coalition of hereditary political
families and big businesses the DP jhf
primary support base includes
unorganized
consumers and labor union members okay
and are you working on anything else at
the moment in addition to the book there
are two new research projects that is on
work that are ongoing right now one of
them is about the tension between
diplomatic commitments and democratic
accountability for instance after the
DPJ took the helm of the japanese
government there has been a tension
between the US government and the
Japanese government regarding what to do
with the US military bases on the island
of Okinawa the DPJ is committed to their
supporters to reallocating relocating
military bases to somewhere else on the
other hand the LDP administration had
already cut a deal with the US
government and we expect a lot of
tensions between electoral
accountability and diplomatic
commitments Japanese government that
South Korean and Taiwanese government
faced a similar situation when they
experienced the partisan turnover in
their own government so I'm organizing
an international joint research project
that explored this important policy
issue aside from that this is my
personal aspiration but I'm thinking
about writing a book about political
culture and rice eating habit in East
Asian civilizations
okay can you expand on that a little bit
more I grew up on a farm as I have just
mentioned and the pattern of
collectivists oriented political
behavior is deeply rooted in rice for me
economic structures historically in East
Asian countries and I'm I'm interested
in exploring this more deeply
analytically okay very good well thank
you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work
thank you very much it's my pleasure for
more information about Professor Saito
and his work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you